right-hander paul blackburn and paul
making his third start since coming back
from triple a las vegas 0-1 a 4-0-9 era
here's joey gallo
at 204 overall and 30 homers he's had an
interesting time
after the trade you know events with the
yankees
he has only 14 hits for them but five of
those have left the ballpark
at the belt gombe sets up away the
delivery is a one-hopper to second
harrison turns he goes to elvis he goes
back to first and the a's get a double
play
and just what the doctor ordered that's
it for the yankees in the first they
failed to score with the a's coming up
in the bottom half jordan montgomery
will pitch for the yankees he's five and
five in a three six nine era uses the
curveball to change up a lot he can't
touch 94 miles an hour now here is matt
olson he's a 275
chopper into the shift
wade's got it and it's a five pitch
inning so three ground balls a very good
start
the last play is a six three three up
and three down we go to the top of the
second nose floor here's luke floyd a
right-handed hitter 265 eight homer is
29 rbis deep in the box oh and sue
there's room in right center golem sets
up outside the pitch is waved at a
cutter away good morning good afternoon
good night now it's jed lowry the dh
today switch hitting veteran 13 homers
for lowry this year
two and two is the count on lowry and
montgomery deals and the [ __ ] cut
anonymous struck him out swinging well
here's canna he's a right-hand hitter
and the o2 breaking ball strike three
beautiful curveball nestling down in the
strike zone right at the knees
so second strike out for monty no runs
one hit
one left at the end of two no score and
here's left hand hitting matt olson to
lead it off
matt olson is going to send one up into
the mount davis area
but it's caught at the wall by gardner
who came streaking into your screen what
a fine running catch by the veteran
outfielder
four hits for oakland all of them
singles so far opportunity now for matt
chapman who grounded his shortstop in
his first at-bat
chapman bounces it to the third
kicks in and everybody's safe a rare
miscue by one of the surest gloves in
the game
wow
and that's how oakland loads the bases
with one away
and the bases are loaded with one man
out and
that will bring up
mark khanna
now the lefty is set and here comes the
payoff to kanna
and it's hit on the ground a short
double play ball flip at the second one
on to first
it's a double play
a 6-4-3 d-p they got him by an eyelash
at first
and oakland does not score
great pitching nice double play
no runs
two hits one error two left
and at the end of four innings of play
no score and the a say yes we want to
take a look
and now we wait and this shouldn't take
long until the game and the answer is
he's safe and the a's get a run and it's
one nothing so one-nothing athletics
most of the yankees were on the bench
they thought the inning was over
so kenna safe and first gets an rbi is
44th of the year and oakland has a
one-nothing lead first and third two out
here is pinder
now here's the 02
to pinder
and the pitch half swing struck him out
breaking balls right
so one run two hits one error two left
and now the end of fournings will play
one nothing oprah
well two on and one out and here is matt
olson olson a lefty hitter with great
power
and he's got first and second one man
out and montgomery deals and the pitch
is looped to third and o'shella makes
the grab right at him
no other play and with two outs here is
jan gomes
with a runner at second voight does not
have to hold the runner on so he can
move a little wider first for the right
hand hitter here is the
0-1 hit on the ground right where lemayo
is playing he throws to first to end the
inning so good for the
positioning by the yankees no runs two
hits
and two left now at the end of five
innings of play one nothing oakland jed
lowry is the lead off in it so 2-2
coming to lowry
and the pitch is swung on and popped him
up to shallow center lemaihue out makes
the catch falls down after he makes the
catch
and there is one away here's chapman
1-1 swung on and driven to right center
and deep guarding back a way back makes
another great running catch
um he is something brett gardner that's
the second one today
and he took a
a double away from uh chapman don't do
that so here is rizzo to pinch it for
wade
the mayhew on deck with two away balling
two strikes to the pinch hitter anthony
rizzo that one gets away from gomes a
wild pitch that will advance sanchez as
the potential tying run into scoring
position
now the lefty you set be another 2-2
and a high pitch is fouled off
and it's dropped by gomes oh my goodness
but here comes a big pitch here's a 3-2
to
anthony rizzo
sanchez off second with two out and the
pitch is swung on and line base head
past third sanchez rounds third coming
home the throw is going to be late it's
a base hit and an rbi for rizzo takes
second on the throw and the yankees have
tied the game at one
so lemay hugh against diekmann he
readies and offers slaughter pulled a
third diving short at grab it's on a
line it stayed in the air and caught by
chapman and the inning is over
but disaster as a run comes in without
the benefit of a hit unearned for sure
two errors in the inning and back to
work for the athletics oakland over six
tonight with chances like this runners
in scoring position and this one will
come to yon gomes who has two singles
today
that'll be a 1-2
and the breaking balls cut out and misty
got out of it great slider down and away
in the inning no runs one hit one arrow
and three left
now at the end of seven innings of play
we tied at one and that'll bring up
canna
green at the belt
delivers to mark and it's swung on in
line to left gallo going over leaping up
it's over his head it's going to the
wall and there's canna he's going to go
to second with a double
it was it so hard that it handcuffed
joey gallo and tony kemp is coming up
here's the pitch by green and tony
drills one down the right field line if
it's fair it's got a chance and down
tony camp a line drive down the right
field line just inside the fell pole in
the bottom of the eighth inning and the
athletics have taken a three to one lead
two away and that'll bring up ershella
now the one-o pitch on the way chaffin
kicks here it is it's swung on a ground
ball to short charging his elbows he's
got it he turns he throws and the a's
have won it